إنه زنزانة حيث يقام هذا الأسبوع بفخر ويختم بعلم أحمر.
يا فتاة صغيرة 2 قمم ، زيادة الأرض لتقف منتصبة ،
التغيير الأول هو الرفاهية
[موسيقى]
كما اخفناه في مكان شبابنا ريمي
أبدا فخور جدا للنظر
أوه ، إنهم المساعدون في غرفتنا.
يصبح العملاق منزلنا
[موسيقى]
حساء خطأ من عمق العقل
أنا في منتصف مدح بون بقليل من القلب
[موسيقى]
اه اه
قبل ذلك بقليل ، اليوم الأول يغلي ، 2 يسيل لعابه الآن
إذا كنت تنجذب إلى المياه المتلألئة والعواطف ، فسوف تستفيد رئيس Ini من الجانب.
تعطيه آه
[موسيقى]
[صفق]
أوو
تفسير
أه الناس نشيطون جنسيا لشبابنا غسيل الملابس حضن دافئ قبل طفرة في التعليم
يفيض التنورة
أوه ، أنا تفيض مع نائب الرئيس في نائب الرئيس الساخنة
آه
[موسيقى]
[صفق]
أوه سمعته بنفسي
[موسيقى]
آه آه آه آه تضيء لنا
نحن نشجع كل الآلهة الذين تحسنوا
[موسيقى]
آه
أوه أوه
[موسيقى]
أوه ، دعنا نذهب ونكتب إعداد Kise
أوه أوه
[موسيقى]